in our series American wonders were
exploring places that make America
wonderful from majestic natural
landscapes to spectacular man-made
creations they don't call it America the
Beautiful for nothing this morning we
show you a recently transformed museum
to celebrate the life and
accomplishments of our 34th president
that of course is Dwight D Eisenhower
it's in his hometown of Abilene Kansas
chip Reid reports from Washington
President Dwight D Eisenhower's time in
office has been called the hidden hand
presidency because of how effectively he
operated behind the scenes he proposed
NASA was instrumental in the civil
rights movement it's a 50 billion dollar
construction project and even created
the interstate highway system that's
like I did a lot of things you don't
know where Don Hammond director of the
newly renovated Eisenhower Presidential
Library and Museum hopes to change that
here is the d-day planning table where
the leadership sat around the actual
table as the supreme Allied commander in
Europe during World War two
Eisenhower planned the invasion of
Normandy this is General Eisenhower
speaking to the troops expeditionary
force
you are about to embark upon the Great
Crusade toward which we have striven
these many months that military service
shaped his presidency at the end of the
war he said I hate war as only a soldier
who lived it can and we believe that
that quote set him up for what his
presidency was going to be and
everything he did in his presidency was
to keep the Cold War cold and keep us
out of a battle keep us out of harm's
way he was a warrior who wanted nothing
more than peace is a warrior for peace
Mary Jean Eisenhower Ike's granddaughter
remembers his softer side as a young
girl she spent a lot of time at the
White House a lot of people will come
through like the museum and see all
these serious pictures of him in the war
and all that and they said what do you
remember best about him and I would say
it's just belly laugh his belly laugh
yes it would come from the back of his
toe and all the way up you know and when
he laughed his life was so funny it
didn't matter whether it was funny or
not you had to laugh to the museum's
renovations also highlight another vital
reason for Ike's success Mamie his wife
of more than 50 years
Mamie says a wife plays a very big part
and what she meant was in the military
career I bought into the partnership
ideas strongly so she knew her her role
in this relationship and she and she did
it and she did it well they were
completely different but they had these
two skill sets that together created
this couple that was so necessary for
our world
you know Eisenhower's presidency in the
1950s was not just a very prosperous
time a lot of people don't know or
forget it was also a very frightening
time it was the beginning of the Cold
War and historians give a kaizen how are
a lot of the credit for keeping tensions
with the Soviet Union from spiraling out
of control and Tony Abilene Kansas is
not the only place you can go soon
you'll be able to come here to learn
about Ike Eisenhower in Washington where
they're building this magnificent
memorial to eisenhower it will be
magnificent I promise under scheduled to
open in the spring plain why you were
standing
construction sat there for a train chip
Reid for his beautiful piece chip thank
you very much